universal health care is a great idea
with
today's top-of-the-line medical
treatment no one should be restricted
from getting health care due to
financial limitations
though this is a fine proposal in theory
medicare for all
is not the way to accomplish this and
here's why
well starting off as you guys probably
already expected
the largest limitation in implementing
medicare for all
is of course economical cost and i'm not
just talking about the cost from a
macroeconomical level
but more importantly from a personal
level as well
one of the most famous proposals for
extending medicare for all
has come from representative
ocasio-cortez who has proposed a 40
trillion dollar plan over the next 10
years out of which 32 trillion
is for universal medicare representative
cortez
claims that medicare for all would save
the american people
a very large amount of money but i'm not
quite sure about this
as the numbers don't work out very well
when we do the math
32 trillion dollars over a 10-year span
comes out to 3.2 trillion
on an annual basis we all know that
that's a lot of money
but it's quite hard to visualize when
it's such an incomprehensibly large
number
so let's take a look at how much that
translates to per
american resident the united states
population currently stands at 328
million people
so if we divide the 3.2 trillion dollars
amongst the u.s population
we get an individual cost of 9756
dollars per year
in other words health insurance for the
average family of four
comes out to thirty nine thousand twenty
four dollars per year
that's nearly double the average premium
for family coverage today
which stands at twenty thousand five
hundred seventy six dollars per year
for single individuals the numbers are
not as bad
as it's only about two thousand six
hundred dollars more per year
but that's still nonetheless a pretty
noticeable increase
now you may be saying that this money
would just come from the rich
so it doesn't matter but here's the
thing
the goal of universal health care is to
simply provide
everyone with good health care as
cost-effectively as possible
so in that case wouldn't it actually
just be better for the government to pay
citizens premium
to private insurance companies instead
of expanding medicare to everyone
as private insurance companies premiums
are significantly cheaper
that's definitely something to consider
but we have
even larger issues to deal with first of
all if the government provides everyone
with medicare
the cost of health care is without a
doubt going to skyrocket
this is precisely what happened as the
government started to back student loans
private college tuition cost fifteen
thousand one hundred and sixty dollars
per year
in the late 1980s after adjusting for
inflation
today they're at thirty four thousand
seven hundred forty dollars
you may be saying that this is just
private institutions
abusing government aid and you would be
partially right
as public institutions are still
significantly cheaper
however the tuition at public
universities has actually increased by a
significantly larger proportion
as they have over tripled since the late
1980s
even after adjusting for inflation and
we'll see the same thing
happen with medical costs because we
can't fully abolish
private healthcare institutions no
matter how good public health care is
a sizable segment of the population will
elect to stick with private health care
for instance even in sweden which is
often touted as having
outstanding public health care 13 of
their employed residents
elect to have supplemental private
health care and
what about our neighbor canada well they
actually have over 80 private health
insurance providers
evidently a certain proportion of the
population will continue to support
private health care
and insurance and though this is usually
the vast minority
these individuals are inadvertently very
influential
here's the thing why do people choose to
go to private health care institutions
well the main reason is better
healthcare even if you had medicare for
all
it'll still be the private companies
that are doing the bulk of the research
thus when they find new cures and
treatments it'll be their private
hospitals that receive them
and they likely spent tens of billions
of dollars on research and development
so they would no doubt want to recoup
these expenses
and likely profit as well the problem is
they have a much smaller amount of
patience
so their development costs would be
heavily concentrated
onto a smaller demographic but this is
not the problem
the individuals who elect to go to
private healthcare institutions
are doing so by choice and they expect
higher costs
the problem arises when the rest of the
public tries to get this new treatment
they'll either have to pay even more and
go to the private institutions
or wait till the technology eventually
makes its way into public hospitals
and something else to consider is that
the best healthcare professionals will
likely be working at private hospitals
now this isn't just a greed field move
most doctors and
surgeons come out of college with
mountains of debt
and they need to get a high paying job
to get out of debt themselves but
unfortunately public health care systems
don't pay doctors anywhere near how much
u.s doctors get paid
in the u.s physicians earn a median
salary of 194
500 meanwhile in the uk
a country with universal healthcare just
take a look at the graph
physicians have to wait 20 years to just
make 81
000 pounds which is just a little more
than 100
000 a year so basically physicians have
to work
20 years in the uk to just see a six
figure salary
not to mention they start off making
just forty thousand pounds per year
and when you have over two hundred
thousand dollars in student loan debt
which is growing at five percent per
year
it doesn't matter how kind-hearted you
are it's simply
extremely financially irresponsible to
take on a public physician job
when you could just switch over to the
private side and make multiples more
it already takes the average doctor 13
years to pay off medical debt
making 210 000 per year imagine
if they were just making half of that or
even less
they'd struggle to just keep up with the
interest growth
which would be over ten thousand dollars
per year thus
it only makes sense that they flock
towards private hospitals
so really at the end of the day medicare
for all
would likely make top-of-the-line
healthcare more inaccessible to the
average person
not more accessible and cheaper and we
haven't even addressed the elephant in
the room yet
which is how in the world we're even
going to fund 3.2
trillion dollars per year so far
representative cortez's tax increases
wouldn't even fund a single year's worth
of medicare for all
as it would raise a mere two trillion
dollars over 10
years but we don't even have to look at
taxes
at all to understand that the average
middle class person
would have to take on the brunt of the
cost the total wealth of u.s
billionaires is 3.4 trillion
even if we strip their entire weld we
would only be able to run universal
medicare
for a little over a single year but what
about corporations
they have a lot of money right well
currently
the top 500 most stable companies in the
us
are worth in total 30.5 trillion which
is no doubt very high but even that
is still only enough to run universal
medicare for a little over nine years
so by liquidating the entire riches of
every single u.s billionaire
and every single s p 500 company which
would crash the stock market
and economy put tens of millions of
people out of work
and strip away the services that all of
these companies provide
we would be able to run universal
medicare for a whopping decade
so imagine how short we'll fall if we
just rely on taxing their income
even with tax rates of 80 or 90 percent
for billionaires and corporations
this would only be enough for 10 or 20
of the cost of universal medicare if
that
thus the vast vast majority would have
to come from the everyday person
and if you don't believe me just take a
look at the income tax rates in the
scandinavian countries
they all have income tax rates well into
the 50s
and on top of that they have sales tax
rates in the 20s
and social security rates at seven plus
percent so
the average scandinavian hands well over
sixty percent
if not over seventy percent of their
gross income
to the government on an annual basis
thus
income tax rates of well over 50 percent
are likely to occur for the average
person in the us
as well if we were to switch over to
medicare for all
at the end of the day i am not against
universal health care by any means
i believe that everyone should have
access to health care
and we will eventually get there one way
or another
but at the same time i'm not convinced
at all
that medicare for all is the solution
medicare for all
would simply make top-level healthcare
even more inaccessible to the average
individual
not to mention a significant rise in
premiums for
everyone across the board but especially
for families
and to top it all off the narrative that
billionaires and corporations will pay
for it
is simply false you can tax them one
hundred percent and even if they all
legitimately paid
it's not nearly enough to cover the cost
of universal healthcare
thus it'll be us who end up swallowing
the costly bill
just for mediocre healthcare but that's
just what i think
do you guys have a more economically
feasible solution for the healthcare
problem
in the us comment that down below also
drop a like if you guys agreed that
medicare for all would simply be way too
expensive
and simply unsustainable long term and
of course
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one